[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEORGE MOUNT:
Hello everyone, I'm
George Mount from
the UI Toolkit team,
and I'm here to talk to you
about Android Data Binding.
Before we started this I
sought some random Android
developer out there for
some help in this talk
and I'd like to
introduce you to-- I'm
sorry what was your name?
YGIT BOYAR: Random123.
GEORGE MOUNT: Random123,
why don't you come up here?
[APPLAUSE]
I stole-- I hope you don't mind,
I have some friends in the NSA,
I looked at your laptop and
put it up here on the screen.
You guys, don't tell anyone.
YGIT BOYAR: My code.
So, I love Android.
I love that little green robot.
But as a developer, some
parts I feel are terrible.
I'm writing so
much code, George.
It's like, why is
this like this?
Why all this stupid code here?
Why do I need that?
Like this product image: Set
that, set this, set this.
Did I study computer
science for this?
I don't think so.
GEORGE MOUNT: No.
We've got to have something
better than that, right?
YGIT BOYAR: We have
something in the box.
GEORGE MOUNT: I do!
Let's talk about Android
Data Binding, OK?
All right, let's look at your
code in a little bit of detail.
I see this set
product UI you are
using calling from onCreate.
That's just a pain,
let's get rid of it.
We don't want that.
Instead, let's look
at this onCreate.
Let's, instead, just bind your
layout to this binding code
and then set the
product on there
and let the binding take
care of all the work.
Sound good?
A little better?
YGIT BOYAR: Let's
see about that.
I'm skeptical.
GEORGE MOUNT: Let's
look at your layout.
Wow, you have a lot of
ellipses in your layout, man.
What's up with that?
To make sure that we understand
that it's a data binding
layout, first we add this
layout tag to the outside,
and then we get this
variable, the prod variable,
that we set in onCreate.
And then we can use
that prod variable
anywhere in our layout.
So instead of this ID we can
now access that prod variable.
So, for example, in the
source it's an image problem
so we can access it directly.
The product name, it's a string.
And same with the description.
YGIT BOYAR: There
is a bug, though.
There you go.
You set a price, it's a crash.
GEORGE MOUNT: Shoot.
All right, well our price is--
if you look at the code there
it's a resource, right?
And our resource is a string
and it's doing a format.
We should do better in
our expression, right?
YGIT BOYAR: I expect so.
GEORGE MOUNT: I think so.
One good thing is that now
we can access our layout--
our expression stuff
directly in our layout.
So we can have this access
to the string resource
right there, and
pass a parameter.
We're passing the product price
as a parameter in our resource,
in our layout.
Pretty cool, huh?
YGIT BOYAR: But in
my application things
are not always starting, George.
I'm cool with your demo.
But I have this
application, sometimes
I have a different layout.
Yes, there you go.
It might be on sale.
How do I do this?
I need to write more
code to do this.
GEORGE MOUNT: Whine,
whine, whine, whine.
You want everything, don't you?
We allow you,
inside your layout,
to have some little
dynamism in there.
You can have an expression
that says, if you're on sale
then show this on sale
sign, and if you're on sale
you might also have a
different color for your price.
YGIT BOYAR: Your example is not
very realistic because my price
changes, we're a
dynamic website.
So I do dynamic pricing.
How you handle that?
GEORGE MOUNT: Well, you
have to at least tell us
when it changes.
So let's look at your product.
Your product has a price
and name and image.
You have to just extend
the base observable class,
and then we mark
the things that you
can change that are going
to change as bindable.
And then you have to
tell us when it changes.
So we have this notify property
change and the bindable part--
YGIT BOYAR: But my classes
extend the base class.
I can't extend your class,
that is not possible.
GEORGE MOUNT: Come on!
All right, all right, fine.
We can use an observable
interface instead.
Is that better?
YGIT BOYAR: Maybe,
let's see about that.
GEORGE MOUNT: We'll give you
a little bit of help here.
We'll give you this
property change registry
so you can just tell
us when that happens.
YGIT BOYAR: Yeah,
that's good enough.
GEORGE MOUNT: That's
a little better.
This is a little easier.
It would be nice if we
could just have properties
that are themselves observable.
Wouldn't it be?
Here you can access them
as if it was just the same
with the same expression.
You just say your
prod.image, and even
though it's not a
drawable itself we
pretend that it's a drawable.
It's an observable field
and it's observable double.
Double for price?
YGIT BOYAR: Did you
just double the price?
[LAUGHS]
GEORGE MOUNT: You shouldn't be
using doubles for your prices.
Or, if you have
more blobby data,
like let's imagine
coming from JSON
and you're still
doing development,
everything's up in
the air, you don't
know what it's going to
be like you can use a map.
And that's pretty
nice for prototyping.
YGIT BOYAR: Seems interesting.
How about multiple layouts?
GEORGE MOUNT: Multiple layouts?
I guess you have two
different variables
and different layouts.
YGIT BOYAR: So I like
two activities now?
GEORGE MOUNT: I hope not.
Boy, that would be
a pain, wouldn't it?
In one you're setting a
product and the other one
you're setting the product
list, it's really a pain.
You don't want to
have to do if it's
on the left-- landscape do this,
and if your portrait do this.
So instead what we do is we
merge all of your variables
and we produce one that has the
summation of all the variables
that you need, and the
binding will just say,
"Oh, I only need
these what variables,
and I'll use those in my layout.
The rest of them I'll
just not use at all."
You just set it and
forget it, it's great.
Just like Ronco, right?
YGIT BOYAR: That seems good.
Talk about the down sides.
GEORGE MOUNT: But
wait, there's more.
You don't need to do any
more findViewByID() right?
Because now all your
expressions are right there
in your layout file.
YGIT BOYAR: Yeah
but I run animations
and also put them
into the data binding.
It seems weird.
GEORGE MOUNT: Well, OK.
You still don't
need findViewByID().
If you have a layout a view with
a tag ID in it, then what we do
is we automatically
extract that view
and stick it as a public
static-- final field
in your binding.
So you can access it
directly from binding.
YGIT BOYAR: That sounds good.
GEORGE MOUNT: You really don't
need findViewByID() anymore.
YGIT BOYAR: I don't
write that code.
GEORGE MOUNT: That stuff
is a pain, isn't it?
Also, we have these
automatic properties.
For example, here is
this DrawerLayout,
and there's this is really
nice setter-- setScrimColor.
Wouldn't it be nice to
be able to just tag it
so you could just set it right
there in your layout file?
There's no attribute for that.
Well, we can just kind of sneak
in and say, "Oh, setScrimColor.
That looks a lot like
a scrim color, right?
Just to set it right
in front of it."
So we just look at it
say, "setScrimColor."
Automatically we
just say, OK if you
have this thing with a data
binding expression in it,
then we will look for the set
center with it, that takes
of the same type of parameter.
So in this case the
color scrim is an int,
so we say setScrimColor.
We know exactly what it is.
It's just automatic
for you, you don't
have to create this new
attribute for yourself.
And everyone's
favorite on click.
Pretty awesome.
YGIT BOYAR: Infamous.
GEORGE MOUNT: So we
have this as well,
we can do onClick
with expressions.
Pretty nice.
YGIT BOYAR: How does it work?
GEORGE MOUNT: I think we'll
talk about that in a little bit.
We have all the other
event handlers too,
like onLongClick or onItems.
Whatever, all those things.
onTextChanged is a
real interesting one,
because it's a text
watcher and there
are three handlers on there.
You can just set one of them,
two of them, three of them.
Whatever you want,
it's pretty nice.
How much would you pay?
How much [INAUDIBLE] performance
you would pay for this?
20%?
YGIT BOYAR: No, of course not.
GEORGE MOUNT: 10%?
YGIT BOYAR: Uh, maybe.
GEORGE MOUNT: How about nothing?
YGIT BOYAR: Wow, no way.
He's lying.
GEORGE MOUNT: It
might not be nothing,
depending on how optimal your
code is, but it's pretty good.
I want to bring up my
co-conspirator in this.
Let me introduce
you to Ygit Boyar.
[APPLAUSE]
YGIT BOYAR: Hey, everybody.
I'm Ygit from the
UI Toolkit Team,
I work on data
binding with George.
I'm going to go into some
details on how it actually
works.
As George showed
before the layouts
are a little bit different now.
You have a layout
tag in the root.
This tells us it's
data binding layout.
And we pass it into
the layout grinder,
which processes your layouts,
and then explores a new layout
that the older Android
versions can understand,
which doesn't add a
layout tag anymore,
remove the namespaces
to your first child.
And it also has
some sub-products
from the processing,
it creates a class,
it creates all these public
final fields for your views
with IDs, and it creates the
setters for your variables.
Going into detail, this is
what actually is happening.
We move that namespace
to her first child,
get rid of the layout tag.
And this is done
while your application
is compiled by Gradle.
And then we remove your
expressions add some tag there
so we can find those
[INAUDIBLE] afterwards.
If you had an ID we would
keep it there, and also
create the vies.
As you can see there directly
matching this public file.
You don't need to cast anymore
because we know what type it
is at compile time, so we
just create the variable
with that type.
So, how do we do this?
One important aspect
of data binding
is that almost everything
is done at compile time.
So when we see an
expression like this we--
while your Java code
is being compiled,
we go check, "OK,
this product, we
know what type it is
because you told us."
Now we say, "OK product is
an image field or an image
getter."
We will look for these things.
OK, here we found there
is a drawable returning
getImage method.
Then we check, OK,
I have a drawable,
there is a source attributes.
Can I set this drawable
to the source attribute?
And then we call
set source there.
The cool part is, we
don't need any reflection
to do any of these
things because we do it
at compile time.
So at runtime it is
equal to the code
that you would write yourself.
GEORGE MOUNT: Hey wait
a second, I thought
all databyte [INAUDIBLE]
frameworks needed reflection,
don't they?
YGIT BOYAR: Not the new ones.
GEORGE MOUNT: Not this one?
Oh, nice.
YGIT BOYAR: So for
example-- but is not
true that the
examples are simple.
So you can say I have my
variable, said to this text.
Correct, that's straightforward.
It sets the user of that image.
The source.
I call setSrc which I said
before, which does not exist.
So this is a problem
because the ImageView
doesn't have a setSrc method.
It has a source attribute, but
as a setImageDrawable method,
[INAUDIBLE] you can
pass that drawable.
How does data binding
know about this?
It's done by annotation.
So we had this binding method
annotation which-- you can say,
OK, this is a binding annotation
for a type class ImageView
that attribute a source
and the method is
called setImageDrawable.
So we know that at the resource
maps are setImageDrawable,
if the pass parameters
match we can use that method
to run the binding.
Again, this is done
in the compile time.
What we generate
is the same code
that you will do at
setImageDrawable.
[INAUDIBLE] event handler.
These are a little tricky
because unfortunately Java 7
didn't have any function
parameters, you cannot do them.
So the way this
works is, we know
there's a binding method
that says onClick.
Method setOnClickListner.
OK, what does the
setOnClickListener expect?
It expects a [INAUDIBLE]
.onClickListener
that's an interface or
[INAUDIBLE] and then
the interface has one method.
Now if you look for
that handler.clicked
matches that one method.
Going into the
details, we saw this.
Nice, that the handler.clicked
method receives a view
and this matches so we
create the interface for you
so that Java is happy,
and you're going to tunnel
those calls to our handler.
So you can see
everything is matching.
It just works.
GEORGE MOUNT: You're
stealing my thunder here.
Let's talk about
binding adapters.
Binding adapters are
probably the coolest part
about data binding.
So let's talk about
something a little bit
more complicated than setText.
SetText was a nice
automatic variable.
You can just setText,
it takes in a string--
or, actually to setText
takes in an char sequence
but it's pretty close.
Let's talk about something
more interesting.
We have this ImageView
but we have a large URL,
large image data coming down.
And if we do this,
what's going to happen--
we don't want this
on the UI thread.
It's going to load
everything on the UI thread.
That that's pretty
lousy, I don't like that.
So instead, I'm
going to use a tool.
How about Picasso?
Glyde?
What's your favorite?
YGIT BOYAR: I'd
rather not say that.
GEORGE MOUNT: In
this example whoever
it was who wrote this
expression tried to use Picasso,
but my goodness, Picasso
with context-- that's
a heck of an expression,
and into what do you--
I don't know.
That's lousy.
I don't like this.
We don't want to see that
in our expressions anyway.
So let's do something
else simpler.
Instead, what we're going to
do is create a binding adapter
and we're going to use
the Android source.
We're going to override
what the default behavior is
with our binding adapter.
And instead of doing
the normal stuff
we're going to try to
do something special.
So what we're going to do
is set this binding adapter,
and of course this is an
attribute, an annotation
on our static method here.
And it could be any
static method anywhere.
And we're just going to
look for that static method
with the attribute,
the annotation.
And here we're going to look for
something that is an ImageView
and it takes in a
string as a parameter.
And now what we can do is do
anything we want in that class.
So we have this nice Picasso.
We can use their
context from the view.
We can load the image
in there, and it
can be done all
off the UI thread,
and it's all kind of magic.
Now you can do image source
is equal to some value,
it's great.
But what if you want to do
something more interesting.
Let's imagine you want
to have a placeholder
for your annotation.
Now you have to do this with
Picasso in the same call,
you can't just say,
"in one call it's
called the load in the
other one you do--"
so what we're going
to do is we're
going to merge it all together
into one binding adapter.
This one takes two
kinds of attributes,
and they can work together.
You just take the
parameters in the order
that you've assigned
them in the annotation,
and now you can do whatever
you want in the method.
In this case we're going
to load the URL off-thread,
and in the meantime we'll
load this placeholder image.
[APPLAUSE]
Now sometimes you want to
have some kind of instance
information in your adapter.
And before we were
using static methods.
But what happens if you
want to use an instance?
With the static
method it's easy.
We know what to do.
We can call it directly just
my class static method call.
Very simple to do in the
generated binding class
that we have.
YGIT BOYAR: How do
you get the instance?
GEORGE MOUNT: So we take
out the static what happens?
Where does that
instance come from?
Some kind of instance.
So what we're going to do
is-- the binding framework
is going to look and see, "Oh,
this is an instance binding
adapter.
We need to generate this
method on this class, this data
binding component class."
And this method is
going to be called
get whatever the name of
your adapter class is.
And now it's your
job to implement
to implement this class.
So you've been with
this class, and then you
call setDefaultComponent on it.
Now, there's also
ones if you want
to load a specific
implementation
for a specific
binding if you want.
But most of the
time you probably
want just the default component
that you're going to load.
Then we know exactly
what instance
we're going to load for
your binding adapter.
Very nice.
Now you can also do
this with components.
Now when you're doing
it with a component
if you have some kind of
state you want to get.
Imagine this is a cache
for your images, right?
So you want to load the image
from your cache first, and then
possibly load off-thread.
In this case we need to
go what that instance is.
Where we're going to pass
it as a static method,
but we want to have
some kind of instance
that we're going to
share around to all
the different binding adapters.
So in this case we need to
know what that state is.
So in this case you implement
your data binding component
but you add your
own method to it.
OK?
So when you had your
own method to it,
we don't know anything
about this method,
this is something
that you know about.
But we're going to pass it to
you as the first parameter,
if you'd like.
Now, you can do
whatever you want.
So we have our own cache here
that we can load our data from.
Let's talk a little bit
about best practices.
YGIT BOYAR: Let's go
through some examples.
GEORGE MOUNT: They say
practice makes perfect.
YGIT BOYAR: Practice.
GEORGE MOUNT: Practice, man.
YGIT BOYAR: [LAUGHS]
Internal joke, sorry.
Let's look at some examples.
Data binding allows you to write
some explorations in the XML.
That means I can just send a
web service call from my XML,
right?
Why not?
There's a click listener.
There's an API.
Why should I not do this?
You should not do this.
If you do this, your
application will break.
This is not what
data binding is for.
Data binding and is to put data
into your UI from your model.
So instead of doing
that, have a call
back, have a presenter,
whatever model you prefer.
Just [INAUDIBLE]
the call to the Java
when you do the real thing.
Don't try to do business
logic tree here or something.
Its not going to work.
Another example in a
good way is that, I
want to change this drawable
based on the users [INAUDIBLE]
just reacted.
In that case it's fine.
Just what the eye sees is
a super simple expression.
That's OK, because here's an
advantage, when I look at this
here it's OK, I know that
if the age is this UI
shows this drawable.
Otherwise the other
one is very clear,
it makes my example
better, my code cleaner.
So this is OK.
So you have to decide
it for yourself.
Well, if you do something like
this, [INAUDIBLE] redact it.
I don't understand what this
code is doing when I look
at it, then there's a problem.
It doesn't make sense.
Instead of doing it,
there's something simpler.
If the age is this, the
displayName otherwise redacted.
And the displayName
comes from your model.
If your object doesn't
really have that field, which
it doesn't in this case,
you create a view model
that provides that
information, or you
can make the variable
for your binding layout.
GEORGE MOUNT: I think you took
that from my code, I'm sorry.
YGIT BOYAR: It's not very good.
He got data binding wrong.
GEORGE MOUNT: Hey!
YGIT BOYAR: So if
your real model
can display [INAUDIBLE]
in this example
we make this
displayName bindable.
In return, data binding is
going to generate this BR clause
similar to the R clause,
but for bindable things.
And when the user's last name
is set you can [INAUDIBLE]
that it has changed
and data binding
will keep the UI up to date.
If you have value objects and
you're directly showing them
in your UI, that's
okay to set them
as variables in your
layout, and set [INAUDIBLE]
your generated binding class.
But if this is not the case,
if you need more information
consider using a view model
where you put this information
there, and you can just use
these observable convenience
fields we provide
your view models.
You just set them
and data binding
makes sure of that they
are visible on the UI.
By the way, observables
like those convenience
observable classes
we provide, they're
nice if there are very few.
If you tried to make your
value objects with those things
you're just using a lot of
my memory for no reason.
Don't do that.
But they're nice if
you have a view model
or you could have
them in your activity
if there's something you
want to easily control.
So there's other
examples where you
write the view model
extending the base observable
class because you don't want to
use those convenient classes.
The same example here, when you
the data changes you notify,
and then data binding
takes care of this.
Or you can implement
observable interface,
now we provide this
program to change
registry class which allows you
to dispatch your [INAUDIBLE].
All they have to do is,
just notify PropertyChange
through that class.
And when we add and
remove callbacks,
just send those
calls to this class
and it will take care of it.
The other part is-- This
is a beautiful example.
I know many people have been
asking for this font editor
within TextView.
There's some reasons for that.
You ask the [INAUDIBLE].
Lisa, I don't know
if she's here,
she's created this thing where
I can set my fonts in XML.
I want to do that,
it is much cleaner.
This became very popular,
I like this example.
The good thing
about this example
is it makes your XML very clean.
You look at it, you understand
what it is trying to do.
There's no added performance
cost in all of these things.
So you write the binding
adapter that says,
I know how to set a
font on a textView.
This is all well defined.
In this code you get the font.
You load the typeface.
Set it on the text view.
If this was a real
application you
would probably cache it so you
don't keep reloading the font.
Beautiful.
Another good example
is the image adapter.
I'm using any image
loader here, Glide.
I could say, this adapter
knows how to set a photo URL
and might have a default
but they're not required.
So that if there is only a
photo URL set on the view
we will still call the adapter
the other value you will see
will be the default value,
which is if it is an object
it will be null.
So an integer will be
zero and all the default
values you can imagine.
This way I can write
just one adapter
that can handle multiple
attribute groups.
And if it is an
instance method you
can just create
this AppComponent
that implants the
DataBindingComponent
and just returns
your image adapter.
This is very nice for testing so
that while the test is running
you can basically set the
default, or do nothing,
because no one wants to
call network during a test
unless you are
testing the network.
So I have this mock version here
that I inject during my test.
And it just does nothing.
It uses the default drawable.
So this works one-on-one
with [INAUDIBLE].
You can just say inject
ImageAdapter, create this app
component and for example,
if you are using Dagger 2
this will take care of the rest.
You don't need to
the anything else
and this is a Dagger 2
implementation where we always
say-- We create the
model for the stuff,
and we implement
this, and then Dagger
generates the rest of the code
assuming that you provided it.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GEORGE MOUNT: We were
super fast so we have
time for lots of questions!
YGIT BOYAR: There are two
microphones left and right.
Please use them
to ask questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my question is
about when you use data binding
it's not always obvious what's
happening in the UX editor.
If you understand what I mean.
It would be nice to be
able to provide a default
product, or something to mock
so I can see what a UX looks
like in the editor as well.
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah, that
was one of the first things
that we talked about when we
were talking to the Android
Studio team.
And they were really
excited about data binding
but as you saw in
the last talk, they
are working on some pretty
exciting things right now.
And so they're going to get to
it but they're not there yet.
YGIT BOYAR: I can tell
that code completion is
coming this way of course.
That's good news
for data binding.
And that's one of the
things we should do.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
to inflate ViewStub
according to data binding?
GEORGE MOUNT: You said,
"Inflate new stuff"?
AUDIENCE: ViewStub.
GEORGE MOUNT: Oh yes, there's
a special implementation
for ViewStub because as you
saw we have final classes--
final fields.
So we have a ViewStub
proxy final field for that.
Because ViewStub actually
replaces itself with a view.
So we can't do a replacement
for a final field, right?
So we have a ViewStub
proxy and you
can get either the view, or
the replaced view with it
depending on its status.
AUDIENCE: OK, and it is
possible to parse the data model
to underlying [INAUDIBLE].
YGIT BOYAR: Yes, you
us the same expression
as if you are
passing an attribute.
And if there's a
binding for that class
we know to create the
and pass that variable
as the variable changes.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello, the
current design tab
inside Android Studio sometimes
doesn't render the layout
correctly.
Sometimes there is just a black
screen or something like this.
Are you going to improve this
and will its work with data
binding also?
GEORGE MOUNT: So
we are constantly
improving the Android
Studio layout editor.
So that's going to get
better and better over time,
absolutely.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
you showed the image
loading examples.
How would you go about
canceling the loads when
your UI is torn down somewhere.
YGIT BOYAR: You have the
binding so you can model it--
so for example you
create the binding--
what you are trying
to cancel is--
let's say you are trying
to load user image URL,
and then the image
URL disappeared or--
AUDIENCE: No, I mean like in
Picasso, you can pass a tag
and then cancel every loads
on those tags for example,
when your fragment goes
away, or something like that.
YGIT BOYAR: One option would
be passing that tag as well
to the binding adapter.
Now you can cancel
through Picasso.
Or if there's some
variable in your model
that can control that then,
again, the binding adapter
can handle the canceling.
AUDIENCE: OK, but it's
not really a callback
for tearing down--
YGIT BOYAR: You can pass a
callback variable if want.
For the view tearing
down-- You know
when the view is going away
through the Android view life
cycle, and there
are callback methods
that you can assign
to this binding class.
You can even say, "Hey
stop, don't rebind."
The mandated changes
generated by the binding class
calls your callback,
"I'm about to re-bind."
And now you can say, "No.
Stop.
Don't re-bind."
When you say that you are
responsible to tell it
to re-bind whenever you want.
Which is very useful if you are
using inside the RecyclerVIew.
Recycler gets really upset if
you update the views themselves
directly.
So if you're at the
RecyclerView.Adapter you say,
"Don't change. " And in runs it
through the RevyclerlViews like
item change flaw.
AUDIENCE: OK, I think
that answers my questions.
AUDIENCE: What's the best way
to debug the expressions that
are in the view markup?
Because it's logic effectively
and so if there's a bug
how do you debug it.
How do you step through it?
YGIT BOYAR: Well, you can't step
through the code, the source
code that we generate is
actually visible to you.
It's generated and you can
step through it if you need to.
It's a little bit
on the uglier side
because it's generated code,
but you can't step through it.
You should try to limit what
your expressions look like.
Now we have some things that
make it a lot easier for you
so that you have fewer bugs.
For example, we have a
no coalescent operator
which-- those of you who
have used other languages
know what this is,
but essentially-- says
if the first part is null
then use the second part.
And we also automatically
do null checks
on your expressions.
So if any part of it is null
then the resultant value
is a default value.
So if you call setText
on user.name then,
if user is null, then the
whole expression is null.
You'll see fewer bugs from that.
Like in the best practices you
should limit your expressions
so they're not too complicated.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I would agree.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
When we're using data binding
with recycle views actually,
the documentation
says that we should--
after passing the view
to the view holder
and get the binding clause.
We should use as a
executePendingBindings.
I want to know exactly
what is it like,
because I'll tried
to use on list view
and didn't call that
method and it worked fine.
YGIT BOYAR: It will work fine
but it will-- As the variables
change we don't instantly
go and update the views.
What data binding does
is we just keep track
and wait until the next
animation frame happens.
This helps us to run
less explorations
because it's more efficient.
Plus you can change
your data on any thread.
You don't need to be
on the main thread
while changing your
data, and data binding
will take care of moving
it to the main thread.
Now the way this works is you
wait until the next animation
frame.
From a recycler perspective
for the list view, what it does
is it calls your own
bind method and it
expects the view to be updated
when that method returns.
So if there's any
TextView that you
should set that takes
when that happens,
otherwise the view won't
be measured properly.
The first layout will be wrong.
The next animation frame, data
binding will update that view.
This is going to cause
another layout which
will correct itself.
It looked like it worked
fine, but it actually
did two layouts for no reason.
So you by calling
executePendingBindings,
you sync all the
VFs with your model
so that data binding is not
going to request another layout
and the ListView or RecyclerView
will run the proper layout
calculations.
AUDIENCE: So, the last one.
When you're importing variables
such as Android-- the base
class to use an
expression-- I want
to know if on the
new Android Studio
we actually have error
fix because if you
try to do that expression
of setting visibility,
it actually shows you an
error, even after compiling.
So I want to know if that's
fixed on Android Studios?
GEORGE MOUNT: You
said for compiling?
I shouldn't show you
errors for compiling.
YGIT BOYAR: It
does show an error.
It's a very detailed problem.
While parsing your
expressions we use ANTLR.
We say grammer parser
is very popular.
That model doesn't
work on IntelliJ.
IntelliJ suggests using
another parser called JFlex.
So sometimes these grammars
don't match properly.
So if you have a bug just report
it and we will try to fix it.
We are working on some
other solutions that
will allow us to use ANTLR
parser inside IntelliJ
but there are fundamental
different models,
so it's not very [INAUDIBLE],
but we are working
on making it more reliable.
GEORGE MOUNT: All
right, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]